this is a very tragic it's not only
trying to cool the refugees but I'd
rather tragic to humanity to our
understanding about who we are i Weiwei
is arguably the best-known contemporary
artist alive today years of beatings
detention and house arrest by the
Chinese government only fueled his fame
in the West now living in exile in
Germany the artist has shifted focus
from the repressions of his homeland to
the global refugee crisis my experience
shared a lot of similarities when the
year I was born my father was exiled a
support he was forbidden to write for 20
years I grew up in a condition where his
being completely discriminated and being
mistreated
and yeah it's very similar to refugees
condition the artists debut feature film
human flow which will be released in the
US this week was shot in dozens of
refugee camps in over 20 countries it
chronicles the physical and emotional
journeys of some of the world's 65
million refugees as they flee their
homelands it's going to be a big
challenge to recognize that the world is
shrinking and people from different
religions different cultures are going
to have to learn to live with each other
[Music]
coinciding with the release of the film
Weiwei is unveiling a major public art
project in New York erecting hundreds of
symbolic barriers around the city
it's about territory is about border is
about immigration and of course it has
something to do with current condition
you know to to limit people traveling
band or our bill to the new border to be
made immigration or people even who to
travel government restrictions on the
rights of individuals to travel there's
a major theme in Weiwei's work and life
my passport has been in the position of
a Chinese garment for years I refuse to
me to have the passport limit my my
freedom to travel as an artist I would
have shows in the worldwide institutions
I cannot really attend so trying to
reduce my my voice or my
possibility for creativity in 2015 the
Chinese government returned Weiwei's
passport freeing him to leave China
recently he's been traveling to promote
his film and oversee the installation of
his work in New York City a freedom of
movement the artist wants none of us to
take for granted
[Music]
you